[موسيقى]
هو انا بدات الريشه في سن يعني نسبيا
مقارنه بناس تانيه كبير شويه كنت بداتها
في المدرسه
كهوايه بعدين لما عجبتني الرياضه في
المدرسه فقلت اجربها العبها في النادي
يعني بتاعي فهناك قابلت المدربه بتاعتي
اللي هي هاديه حسني
هاديه عرفتني على الريشه البارالمبيه انا
ساعتها ما كنتش اعرف اي حاجه عن الريشه
البارالمبيه فهاد عرفتني عليها ف قالتلي
في بطوله عالم
هتتعمل و يعني اي حد ممكن يروحها عشان هم
كانوا عايزين ينشروا الريشه البارالمبيه
ساعتها فقالت لي دي فرصه حلوه تروحي فطبعا
الموضوع بالنسبه لي كان مفاجاه كبيره عشان
انا كنت سعيته بلعب كذا حاجه في نفس الوقت
بس كلها كانت فور فن ما كانش في اي حاجه
بلعبها سيرسل يعني رحت بطوله العالم عجبني
الموضوع حبيت الريشه ساعتها ف من ساعتها
وانا بقى يعني يعني بلعب ريشه بس يعني
البطوله بتاع كندا الدوليه كانت من
البطولات المؤهله ل باريس 2024 هي
بطوله اول 12 في العالم بس اللي بيروحوا
فانا لعبت ايفنتين لعبت فردي للعبت
زوجي في
الفردي كان معايا مجموعه صعبه كان معايا
اقويه جدا بس الحمد لله الحمد لله لعبت
ماتشات وحققت نتائج مع ناس في الرانك اعلى
مني ما كنتش حققتها قبل كده ف الحمد لله
كانت كده كويسه في الزوجي دي حاجه جديده
انا بدات العبها بدات العب مع لاعيبه من
امريكا احنا بدانا نلعب في ابريل اللي فات
في بطوله البرازيل الدوليه برضو خدنا فيها
[موسيقى]
ذهب انا عندي هدف عايزه احققه فده بيخليني
اللي هو اراعي
مثلا التمارين اللي بعملها اراعي الاكل
اللي باكله اراعي كل الحاجات دي لان انا
بحاول احقق الهدف ده فدافع ان انا طبعا
ارفع علم مصر
واني واني اعمل حاجه لسه ماعملتش في
الرياضه عشان الريشه البارالمبيه يعني ان
تدخل البارالمبي تعتبر لسه جديده فنفسي
اعمل حاجه برض لسه ماعملتش في الوطن
العربي او افريقيا شافت مثلا كرسي متحرك
اول حاجه بتفكر فيها ان هي المفروض تروح
تزقه بس هو ده مش مش اي حد في كورس متحرك
المفروض اول حاجه تعملها انك تروح تصعد
انت تساله الاول يعني عشان ه في ناس كتير
بتحتاج تتزق بطريقه معينه هي اول حاجه
بتبقى توعيه تاني حاجه تخلي الطرق
اكتر تخليها اكتر اكسبل لكل
الناس دي تاني حاجه وتخلي المواصلات
العامه وكل ده اكتر ا للناس حتى الاود
الاسنسرات اي مباني
عامه كل ده يبقى مؤهل ان هو يستقبل او
يعرف اي حد يخشه وما يبقاش محتاج الى
مساعده بالمعنى المفهوم او مايبقاش حاسس
انه
ا انه يعني في حاجات موقفه ان هو يعمل
حاجات معينه ان كل حد يعرف يعملها حتى لو
كانت بطريقه مختلفه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شويه الرساله اللي احب اقولها ان يعني مش
هقول الرسائل اللي كل حد بيقولها اللي هو
اشتغل كارد والحاجات دي عشان دي بتتقال
كتير لكن يمكن حاجه انا اتعلمتها من تجربه
شخصيه انك تدوري او تدور على حاجه
تحب حاجه
تخليك يعني تبقى عندك هدف قريب مش هدف
اللي هو يقعد العمر كله بس هدف قريب
وتشتغل عليه كل يوم وبعدين بس في نفس
الوقت بعد ما يبقى عندك الهدف ده وتشتغل
جامد عليه وكده ما تنساش ان في فتره انت
تحقق الهدف ده ان في حاجات تانيه اخرى في
الحياه عشان دي حاجات حاجه انا بنساها
ساعات ان غير الريشه في حاجات تانيه كتير
بتحصل المفروض ما انسهاش عشان انا العمر
مش هيرجع وهعرف اعمل كل الحاجات
التانيه